hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy I'm not entirely
certain how helpful this video will be
but I know that I like to look at
pathways you know from a big I like to
see the big picture and kind of what's
going on overall so I hope that this
summary will kind of help under help you
understand what's going on with with the
overall process of cholesterol synthesis
and the reactants and requirements so on
and so forth the question would be maybe
like how many acetyl co a czar used
melville on AIDS made cos use lost ATP
use etc things like that and I want to
think about that here in this video but
one thing that I have to know is that
anything that I say will be excluding
the 19 steps between lemma sterile and
cholesterol because I don't actually
know what happens there so everything
else that we've covered though we should
kind of think about you know what's used
what's what happens there so let's let's
do this let's think about the stages
going backwards starting from one
cholesterol molecule so we have 127
carbon cholesterol molecule here and it
came from squalene and in this process
we used 1 NADPH and we lost 3 carbons 2
as carbon dioxide and one is formic acid
here ok so how do we get the squalene
the squalene came from from the
condensation of 6 IPP molecules each of
them of course being 5 carbons now two
of them were converted to DM a PP in
order to actually have the reactions
occur but the DM a PP is came from IPP
so it's not unfair to say that 6 IPPs
were just put together to make squalene
and that of course required an NADPH
where did we get these IPPs from we got
them from Avalon 8 each of them and in
each of those reactions we lost 1 carbon
dioxide and we were used up three ATP's
if we total that up that that means
we've got there
what is that three times six all right
so that's 18 ATP molecules used and here
we have six carbon dioxide's that leave
produced how do we get these metal on
eights well each melville on eight came
from a reaction of basically putting
together three acetyl co a s and putting
together these three two carbon
molecules to give one mevalonate
required to NADPH s if that's going to
happen six times to produce these metal
on eights that's six times to NADPH is
that is 12 NADPH is there
nad pH is used and how many acetyl co
ways do we have here well we have three
for each of these reactions there are
six total reactions 3 times 6 is 18
acetyl co a is 18 acetyl co is okay so
we have 18 acetyl co is we get 6 metal
on dates out of those by using 12 NADPH
is the six methyl on AIDS are each
converted to IPP losing one carbon
dioxide each time and using ATP 18 ATP
molecules to get there and then we use
another NADPH here so if we consider the
start counting these 12 that would that
would be 13 right there to make the
squalene and 14 there to make the
cholesterol so we use 14 total NADPH is
used we had we said how many ATP's we
said 18 ATP's 18 total ATP molecules
used and how many carbon dioxide's were
produced we had six here going from
Avalon eight to IPP and then we lost two
up here as well so that's going to be 18
carbon dioxide's
produced
eight carbon dioxide's produced so I
hope that this I mean I don't know how
meaningful these numbers really are but
I kind of like to look at the overview
and this is kind of messy and kind of
crazy so for you to pause it and stop it
and look at this a little bit more
carefully please do so but I wanted to
kind of show you the big picture and as
far as what goes into creating one
cholesterol molecule so I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
thanks for watching and be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone you think might find it
helpful thanks happy studying